RIGHT.
AND TO A WE DON'T HAVE A CAR WE
NOW BUT WOULD HAVE TO MEMBERS
ARE READY TO PERCENT SO I LIKE
TO. GIVE THE SUBCOMMITTEE HE
STARTED AND.
OUTDOOR GARCIA.
PRESIDENT.
GOOD MORNING THIS CHERRY
COLLEAGUES.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR IS THAT.
BILL THAT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM'S FRAUD
PROGRAM UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA. CULTURAL AND
HISTORIC ENDOWMENT
THIS PROGRAM BUILDS OFF OF THE
CURRENT FEDERAL PROGRAM AND
WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO MUSEUMS
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES BY
ENCOURAGING MUSEUMS TO OFFER
FREE.
OR LOW COST ADMISSION TO
INDIVIDUALS PRESENTING AN EBT
CARD AND A VALID FORM OF AN ID
THIS BILL. ALSO WOULD FURTHER
THE VISION OF A GOVERNOR BROWN
AND CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO
ENHANCE OPPORTUNITIES.
APPEAR MUSEUM AND CULTURE
PROGRAMS THAT MAKE MUSEUMS
ESSENTIAL PLACES WITHIN.
COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
HAVE A WITH ME PAMELA ZARETSKY
WHO HERE TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF IT.
BAM BAM.
ALRIGHT BUT WE HAVE THEM.
ADDITIONAL VOICES TO SUPPORT A
BETTER.
I SEEM COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS AND MUSEUMS ACROSS THE
STATE. IN SUPPORT OF AB IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR CALIFORNIA
MUSEUMS FOR ALL.
MY NAME IS JOAQUIN ORTIZ AND I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF INNOVATION AT
THE MUSEUM A PHOTOGRAPHIC ARTS
IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA.
RECENTLY I WAS SPEAKING TO YOUNG
SMOLYAN WOMAN. WHO LIVES IN THE
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD OF CITY
HEIGHTS IN SAN DIEGO? IT'S
ACTUALLY NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE I
WENT TO SCHOOL AS A TEENAGER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
FROM HER COMMUNITY DON'T GO TO
MUSEUMS
AND THE PRIMARY REASON WHY IS
THAT THE COST OF ENTRY.
I LOOK BACK ON MY TIME LIVING IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD AND GOING TO
SCHOOL THERE. IT'S A
NEIGHBORHOODS VERY NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART.
AND HOW I DON'T SEE THOSE
RESIDENTS COMING TO MUSEUM LIKE
MINE.
I WANT THEM TO FEEL WELCOME
INCLUDED IN WHAT WE DO.
AND I KNOW THAT IS NOT EASY FOR
MUSEUMS LIKE MY TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES.
IT'S MY ROLE AS DIRECTOR OF
INNOVATION TO FIND SOLUTIONS FOR
CHALLENGES LIKE THESE.
WE KNOW THE GIVING FREE OR
REDUCED ADMISSION.
ALLOWS THESE KINDS OF MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
TO GIVE THEM GREATER ACCESS AND
EQUITY TO THESE IMPORTANT
CULTURAL EXPERIENCES.
AS A LEADER TO SMALL MUSEUM.
I ALSO KNOW HOW TOUGH IT IS.
TO MAKE THESE OPPORTUNITIES A
REALITY WHEN IT COMES TO MONEY.
SMALLER MUSEUMS RELY ON THE
INCOME FOR ADMISSIONS TO SUPPORT
THEIR WORK.
IN BALBOA PARK IN SAN DIEGO. WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF SMALLER MUSEUMS
LIKE THAT MODEL RAILROAD MUSEUM.
RECEIVE EAGLE OUR INSTITUTE AND
THE VETERANS MUSEUM AND MEMORIAL
CENTER. AND THEY WOULD NEED
FUNDS LIKE THESE IF THEY WANT
OPEN ACCESS TO THESE KINDS OF
COMMUNITIES.
A PROGRAM LIKE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUMS FOR ALL SUPPORTS US IN
ALLOWING US TO DO THAT.
SMALL MUSEUM STRUGGLE TO TAKE
THESE KINDS OF RISKS TAP OFFER
FREE OR REDUCED MISSION.
IN THIS BILL SUPPORTS US IN
TAKING THAT LEAP.
CALIFORNIA MUSEUMS FOR ALL
ALLOWS US TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE
OF THOSE WHO TRADITIONALLY NOT
BEEN INCLUDED.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE THE LEAST
LIKELY TO COME DOOR MUSEUMS BUT
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO NEED THE
MOST OPPORTUNITY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AND ALL THAT YOU DO
FOR US THANK YOU.
HELLO.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR CALIFORNIA MUSEUMS
FOR ALL. MY NAME IS AMANDA ROSS
IN AND I AM THE MAJOR GIFTS
OFFICER AT THE SAN JOSE MUSEUM
OF ART IN THE HEART OF SILICON
VALLEY. SAN JOSE AND THE SILICON
VALLEY REPRESENTS FROM MANY
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD A PLACE
OF INNOVATION AND CREATIVITY YET
IN A CITY WITH A POPULATION OF
ONE MILLION PEOPLE. MANY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS DO NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE THE
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS MUSEUMS
RESIDENTS CAN ACCESS INNOVATIVE
AND CREATIVE ENVIRONMENTS.
THE SAN JOSE MUSEUM OF ART IS A
PARTICIPATING MUSEUM IN THE
NATION WIDE EFFORT OF MUSEUMS
FOR ALL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN FAMILIES. TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT THE
SOUNDS HE MUSEUM OF ART BY
APPLYING FOR THE NATIONAL
MUSEUMS FOR ALL PROGRAM HOWEVER
CURRENTLY THERE IS NOT A STRONG
INSTITUTIONAL MARKETING EFFORT
THAT IMPOSSIBLE STAFF AND
RESIDENTS OF THIS CULTURAL
OPPORTUNITY. THIS PROGRAM WILL
SUPPORT MUSEUMS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THAT CAN HELP
BRIDGE A GAP.
THIRD THOUGH THERE IS A NATIONAL
MUSEUM FOR ALL PROGRAM IS A
STATE EFFORT THAT WILL HELP
BUILD A STRONG MARKETING BETWEEN
MUSEUMS IN THE COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWO MUSEUMS
IN SILICON VALLEY AND SAN JOSE
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING MUSEUMS
FOR THE NATIONAL EFFORT. AND
THERE ARE OVER TWENTY MUSEUMS
THE SILICON VALLEY ALONE THAT
CAN BENEFIT FROM A CALIFORNIA
EFFORT THAT ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS
TO GAUGE WITH MUSEUMS.
THE SAN JOSE MUSEUM OF ART
SUPPORTS THE BILL'S INTEND TO
CREATE A CALIFORNIA BASED
PROGRAM THAT WILL OFFER.
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WITH
ELECTRONIC BENEFIT TRANSFER EBT
CARDS.
FREE OR LOW VERY LOW COST
ADMISSION TO MUSEUMS AND PROVIDE
A MODEST GRANT PARTICIPATING
CALIFORNIA MUSEUMS.
AT THE SAN JOSE MUSEUM OF ART
RESTRAIN I'VE TO GIVE PEOPLE
FROM ALL COMMUNITIES ACCESS TO
OUR AND ITS POWER TO INSPIRE
CHANGE.
ACCESS PROGRAMS SUCH AS MUSEUMS
FOR ALL OUR KEY TO ATTRACTING
INDIVIDUALS FROM A VARIETY OF
BACKGROUNDS AROUND.
BACKGROUNDS AROUND THE JOINT
IMPACT OF THE CREATIVITY THAT
CONNECTS THEM.
WE VALUE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. IN BROUGHT ME MUSEUM
THERE AUDIENCES AND HELPING
MUSEUM SERVE ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF IT
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PLEASE.
.
COME UP TO THAT MICROPHONE AND
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATIONS.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR JASON FELT
ABOUT HER CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY.
PUBLIC WORKER OF ANY OF POSTING.
ANYBODY WHO ARE OPPOSING THIS.
BECAUSE.
WELL PLEASE COME FOR.
KEYNESIAN DOWN AND QUESTIONS
YEAH HAS JUST
BUT NOT A GENERAL QUESTION MAYBE
JUST FOR THE RECORD.
I I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL BUT.
JUST TO CLARIFY A COUPLE THINGS
I WISH I WAS NOTICING THAT.
IN. THE ANALYSIS THAT.
THIS IS AN OPTIONAL PROGRAM TO
THE AUTHOR MISTER MISTER SEE AN
OPTIONAL THAT'S GREAT ALL
AROUND.
BUT IT WOULD WAS STRUCK ME AS
INTERESTING AS SOME OF THE
WORDING IS THE SAYS THAT.
EXHIBITIONS ARE ATTRACTIONS AT
NORMAL CARRYING EXTRA AT ON FEE
SUCH AS IMAX MOVIE SCREENS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO BE COVERED BY
THE FEAR DISCOUNTED RATE.
SO IT'S OPTIONAL BUT IF THEY
CHOOSE TO DO IT THEY STILL CAN
CHARGE MORE FOR THE IMAX OR
WHATEVER. OTHER PART THAT
THEY'RE GOING WHAT OTHER ADDED
FEE THERE WOULD BE ON THAT SO
YOU CAN GET INTO SAY THE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WAS AT THE
CALIFORNIA'S
SCIENCE CENTER THE ONE AND.
IS ONE LA YOU HAVE WELL I AM ONE
OF THE LA AND THEN THERE'S
THERE'S NOT IMAX ATTACHED TO
EACH STOP PAY SEPARATE FOR THE
IMAX CORRECT IT WOULD BE GETS
AWAY WITH IT AND RIGHT NOW I
BELIEVE YES OKAY. YEAH AND THEN
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'VE GOT A
BUDGET REQUEST IN FOR THIS TO
VOTE FOR THE FUNDING BECAUSE
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO FUNDING
ATTACH OKAY. GREAT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY A COUPLE THINGS ON ADDED
SO THAT HE GOT A SIMILAR BILL
LAST YEAR THAT. WE SUPPORTED
THAT'S CORRECT YEAH.
FORGET I IN APPROPRIATIONS
THERE WERE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT.
.
WHICH MUSEUMS THAT MAY BE
INCLUDED OR NOT AND SO WHERE.
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS WE
SPEAK WITH A LOOK FOR HOUSING
AND. MOVE FORWARD AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WANT
TO CLOSE JUST THAT ONE THINK
JOAQUIN AMANDA FOR A TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK AFTER RIVAL
RICK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THIS BILL DOES ENJOY AND. EARNED
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. WILL
HAVE A QUORUM WILL.
TAKE A BALLOT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
EVERY DAY.
MOST GO BLOOM.
RE PRESENTING AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY SIX.
LORD FURIOUS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SIGN HERE PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY SIX WHICH IS A BILL
RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL GRANT PROGRAM.
THE PROCESS FOR APPROVING GRANT
APPLICATIONS AT THE ARTS COUNCIL
INCLUDES A PEER REVIEW PANEL
THAT IS COMPRISED OF EXPERTS IN
VARIOUS. ARTISTIC FIELDS WHO
REPRESENT A WIDE ARRAY OF
DIVERSE GROUPS AND COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
AUTHORITY.
PROVIDE SOME AUTHORITY TO THE
OUT ARTS COUNCIL TO PROVIDE AN
HONORARIUM TO MEMBERS.
THE PANEL FOR THEIR.
TIME. I THAT.
TIME TYPICALLY IS.
A GOOD DEAL OF TIME IS TAKEN TO
MEET WITH REVIEW AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AFTER GRANT
AWARDS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT SINCE
PANELISTS ARE OFTEN CHALLENGED
IN THEIR ABILITY TO AFFORD THE A
SPAT EXPENSES THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE GRANT
PROCESS.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX IS THE
BEST WAY TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF GRANT REVIEWERS AND WILL HELP
EXPEDITE THE FLOW OF ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ALREADY GIVEN TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL.
SUPPORT THE GRANTEES AND NEW
PROGRAMS WHICH OF COURSE IS THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOAL. THE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE HONORARY
WILL IMPROVE THE COUNCIL'S
ABILITY. TO INVOLVE A DIVERSE
GROUP OF GRANT PANELISTS WHICH
WILL OFFSET THE COST THE
PANELISTS WILL OTHERWISE HAVE TO
BEAR AND WILL ENSURE DIVERSITY
IN THE PROCESS.
I HAVE THOUGHT AND BOUND
CRAWFORD WITH ME HERE TODAY WHO
IS AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND IS BOUND CRAWFORD IS THE NEW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
ARTS CAL.
BUT BUT BUT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
HOW AM THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM? FOR SUPPORTING AN
AUTHORING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE. FOR.
ATTENUATING TO SUPPORT THE ARTS
AND CREATIVITY IN CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR HIGH FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THAT. I AM AS YOU HEARD AND
BROWN CRAWFORD I'M THE NEWBIE
HERE.
M. CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL. I
THINK I'VE REACHED MY HUNDREDTH
DAY.
SO. KM I'M STILL SHINY.
OUR I WAS APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN IN DECEMBER AND STARTED IN
JANUARY. I'M AN EDUCATOR I'M
ARTS EDUCATION ADVOCATE
AND I'M A CREATIVE ECONOMY
CHAMPION AND A RURAL RESIDENT.
EVEN THOUGH I WAS RAISED IN
CHICAGO I'VE BEEN UP IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY FOR FOUR DECADES.
SO THEM I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPOSSESSED
FROM THE REST OF THE STATE.
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO NOW.
WHICH I'M ENJOYING BY THE WAY.
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK AS YOU
HEARD ON BEHALF OF AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY SIX.
YEAH I'M A BILL FOR THE COUNCIL.
YOU ALL KNOW THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL IS THE STATE'S ARTS
AGENCY. AS A DIRECTOR I WORK
ALONGSIDE THE STAFF AND THE
COUNCIL BODY ITSELF WHICH ARE
ALL APPOINTEES. AM NINE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR ONE BY
THE ASSEMBLY AND ONE BY THE.
SENATE.
THROUGH THIS BILL WERE SEEKING
AUTHORIZATION TO PROVIDE PEER
REVIEW PANELISTS AN HONORARIUM.
AND THE PRACTICES COMMON IN
OTHER STATES AND.
PUREVIEW PANELS ARE SET AT THE
CORE OF WHAT WE DO. M. AS A
GRANT MAKING. GRANT FUNDING
ORGANIZATION AS PART OF A MULTI
STEP. THE OUR PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE FOR REVIEWING ALL OF OUR
GRANT APPLICATIONS.
AS A STATE AGENCY WE BEGAN THE
CONVERSATION ON THE ISSUE WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND.
GOVERNOR BROWN APPROVED OUR
ABILITY TO BRING FORTH A. B..
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX. THAT
WILL ALLOW THE ARTS COUNCIL TO
CLEAN UP ARE ENABLING
LEGISLATION SO BETTER REFLECTS
THE WORK THAT WE DO TODAY.
AND OUR AGENCY BUDGET HAS
INCREMENTALLY INCREASED OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
WHICH IS WONDERFUL HIM WITH THAT
INCREASE IN BUDGET OUR NEED FOR
PEER REVIEW PANELISTS HAS
ALREADY INCREASED.
AND IT.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
GRANT APPLICATIONS RIGHT NOW.
FULLER ARE THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
FUND. AND WE ANTICIPATE EIGHTY
PUREVIEW PANELISTS TO COME AND.
ADJUDICATE THOSE GRANTS.
AT THAT.
MAKES UP MORE THAN TWENTY PANEL
MEETINGS.
YEAH I'M EACH MEETING LAST FROM
ONE TO THREE DAYS AND CONSISTS
OF BETWEEN THREE TO FIVE
PANELISTS.
THIS ISN'T A FUNDING REQUEST
BUT.
IT SIMPLY ALLOWS US THE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE THE
HONORARIUM FOR EACH DAY OF
SERVICE FOR EACH PANEL MEMBER
WHEN THEY COME TO SACRAMENTO.
THE LEGISLATION WILL HELP US
BETTER REFLECT THE UNIQUENESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S SIZE AND DIVERSITY.
AND.
SHOW RESPECT TO THOSE WHO SERVE
OUR HOPE TO SERVE IN THIS
CAPACITY.
HAD ON THE PANELISTS INSURE THAT
ARE GRANT APPLICATION REVIEW
PROCESS IS DEMOCRATIC FAIR AND
REPRESENTATIVE. OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE GEOGRAPHY. DIFFERENT
TYPES AND SIZES OF
ORGANIZATIONS.
DIFFERENT AGES RACIAL ETHNIC
GENDER IDENTITIES AND MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
PANELIST SUPPLY THROUGH AN OPEN
PUBLIC APPLICATION PROCESS.
AND OUR COUNCIL REVIEWS AND
APPROVES
POR PANELISTS EACH YEAR.
PANELISTS HAVE IN DEPTH
EXPERIENCE IN VARIOUS OUR
PRACTICES DISCIPLINES AND A.
.
THERE THEY RANGE FROM ARTS
LEARNING.
PRE K. THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE
CULTURAL DEVELOPMENT JUVENILE
AND ADULT. PROGRAMMING IN
CORRECTIONS.
YEAH I NONPROFIT MANAGEMENT
MEDIAN TECHNOLOGY ARTS IN
HEALING UM AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH.
VETERAN POPULATIONS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OTHER RELATED
FIELDS.
WE. HAVE EMERGING AND EXPERIENCE
ARTS ADMINISTRATORS. ARTISTS AND
ARTS POLICY MEMBERS THAT WE
ENCOURAGED TO APPLY TO BE. A
PANELIST.
THOSE WHO ARE ABLE TO SERVE NOT
ONLY GIVE THEIR TIME AND
EXPERTISE BUT RECEIVE GREAT
VALUE IN THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT THEY GET FROM
BEING PART OF THAT PROCESS.
AND THE GROWTH THAT COMES FROM
THAT.
BEING INVOLVED IN THAT SO WHEN
THEY GO BACK TO THEIR. AND
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE ABLE TO USE
WHAT THEY LEARNED THROUGH THE
PROCESS IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
SO IT'S A BALANCED EQUATION.
IT AT THAT THINK.
EQUATIONS LIKE THIS SHOULD NEVER
BE ON BALANCE SO AS MUCH AS THEY
GIVE THE TAKE HOME.
AS READ RECENTLY TALKING TO
PANELISTS IT BASED THAT'S THE
FIRST THING THAT THEY SAY IS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
CLAIM LEARNING SO MUCH.
AND SOME REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
PANELISTS A NEED TO BE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THE NEED TO
COMMIT TO AGREE TO ACCESS. AND
REVIEW SIXTY UP TO SIXTY
APPLICATIONS AND ALL THE
ATTENDANT WORK SAMPLES BEFORE
THEY GET.
IN MY GOING OVER TIME.
OKAY BEFORE THAT BEFORE THEY
GET.
TO THE WORK AND AGREED TO
TRAVEL TO SACRAMENTO.
.
WHEN THEY GET TO SACRAMENTO THEY
COLLECTIVELY REVIEW AND RANK ALL
THE APPLICATIONS.
I THINK THAT FOR ME THE SHORT
ANSWER SINCE I NEED TO WRAP UP
IS THAT THIS IS ABOUT SHOWING
RESPECT
AND AND. AND DOING WHAT.
MANY OTHER ARTS AGENCIES DO IS
SHOW THAT RESPECT THROUGH
HONORARIUM AS.
.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS BEFORE I.
GOOD DO WILL BE OPPORTUNITY FOR
TO QUESTIONS OVER OKAY GOOD I
LIKE I SAID I'M A NEWBIE SO. ARE
YOU HAVE A CRYSTAL ELECT AS
SOMETHING QUICKLY TO.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR CHU AND AND THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT WITH.
.
YOU KNOW WELL OVER A THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
THIS YEAR AND OVER OF. OVER TEN
THOUSAND NONPROFIT ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT EXIST IN THIS
STATE WE KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE MANY THAT WE AREN'T
FUNDING AT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
OUR PROCESS.
IS OUT REACHING TO THE WHOLE
STATE AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND AN EXCELLENT WAY.
WE BELIEVE THAT CAME OUR
PANELISTS WILL REALLY FACILITATE
THAT.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A NOMINAL
AMOUNT ALSO JUST WANTED TO POINT
OUT TO THE TWO HANDOUTS THAT YOU
HAVE. ONE OF THE HANDOUTS
ILLUSTRATES OUR PROCESS YOU CAN
SEE HOW THE MONEY GETS OUT THE
DOOR. ON WE CAN THAT'S KIND OF A
HELPFUL WAY TO SEE HOW THIS ALL
WORKS
AND THE OTHER IS.
A DOCUMENT THAT LISTS ALL THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
I'M MORE HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THOSE PROGRAMS IF YOU WISH AND
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO. INVITE
YOU WE ARE PLANNING ON HAVING
THAT.
ARTS IN VETERANS HEARING WITH
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE WE
BELIEVE ON THE TWENTY SECOND OF
MAY.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OF
BEFORE I CALL ON THE.
.
DO YOU KNOW OF A OPPOSITION TO
COME UP HERE I LOOKED AND
NOTICED I WOULD HAVE A QUORUM SO
I'M GOING TO. CALL THIS THE.
.
COMMITTEE ALL ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET. MEDIA ONTO ORDER AND I
WOULD ASK THE SECRETARY TO
PLEASE.
CALDERON.
KANSEN CHU YOUR KANSEN CHU HERE
WALDRON.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN TREATMENT HERE MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
THIS HEARING HERE.
GREAT SO WOULD WILL HAVE A
QUORUM AS TO ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FOR.
ACTUALLY SPORT AUDITORY WILL
CONTINUE. ADDITIONAL.
SO SUPPORT PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION SHORT
ADJACENT SHELTER ABOUT
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINK THE AUTHOR
AND.
IT TAKES WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN ANY QUESTIONS.
SOON THE.
THANK YOU THINK STILL AUTHORED
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
ALSO. AND.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME.
TO STATES SERVICE I JUST HAD A
QUICK QUIP TWO QUICK QUESTIONS
ONE WAS WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE
RANGE.
OF.
OF THE HONORARIUM IS AND THEN.
SECOND IS.
IT IS THIS GONNA BE COMING OUT
OF CURRENT BUDGET OR REQUEST
THAT FUNDS.
IN THE FUTURE.
SO THIS WILL COME OUT A CURRENT
BUDGET AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
THINKING THE RANGE YOU KNOW AT
AS OUR BUDGET WILL ALLOW.
PROBABLY AROUND A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A DAY.
WHEN THEY'RE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
NOT WHEN THEY'RE REVIEWING
THINGS AT HOME.
A ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
THREE KNOW WOULD TO HAVE THE THE
MOTION AND THE SECOND.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING UP HERE.
รณ I WOULD DO I DO HOW OF.
NO BUDGET ASK TO INCREASE TO
FUNDING FOR FEAR THAT THE ARTS
COUNCIL.
AND I'M HOPING THAT.
THOSE MEMBERS THAT MAKE A
MOTION REMEMBER TO SECOND THE
MOTION A MEMBER STEP PERCENT OF
BILL. AND ALL THE WITNESSES TO.
OR HOW MAY GET DHEA COULD DO TO.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUR
CON CALL OUR COUNSEL FOR NEXT
YEAR SO PLEASE THAT AFFECTS YOUR
MUSCLES.
NO WAS THAT.
BUT DON'T SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.%
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
SIX BLOOM TO DO PASSED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON.
ACOSTA ON ACOSTA AYE DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
THIS AREA I.
THANK YOU CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU THOUGH THOU WILL BE. HOLDING
OPEN A HOME FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MITCHELL WE GO BACK TO.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
RIGHT. RIGHT.
WILLIAM LOVINGLY HEALTH HAZARD.
BUT WHICH ONE.
BURGER QUICKER THE FRIEDMAN
ARTICLE.
THIRTY WHO VOTED DISTILLING.
IT'S AN ECONOMIST ON HOME OKAY
GREAT.
ALREADY.
HOME WE WOULD HAVE ONE ITEM ON
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE NUMBER
THREE DAVIES THIRTY TO FIFTY
SIX.
AND.
WILL HAVE A HAVE A TWO PASS AND
A RECOMMENDATION. AND TELL LIKE
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THANK YOU.
WHO DO HAVE A MOTION AND THE?
BUT HAS SERVED TO REPLACE
CALDERON.
KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON.
ACOSTA I ACOSTA AYE DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I. MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
IT'S VERY AND I. WILL HAVE A
FORMER BRIDGES.
I ON THE CAN FAIL YOU. WALDRON
AYE GREAT.
A VOCAL FACTOR AB NEED EIGHT AND
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR EDUARDO
GARCIA DO YOU PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
KANSEN CHU AYE KANSEN CHU AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE ACOSTA. THE
CONSTANT NINE DAVID CHIU.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
THE VERY AND I.
ORAL MOTOR ROAD OPEN FOR ANOTHER
FIVE MINUTES OR SO.
FOR THE ABSENT A MEMBER TO AT
ALL. TAKE YOU VERY MUCH.
AND.
I WILL CALL THE ROLL.
HELLO.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THANK YOU.
I WOULD.
OF FOR.
CARNIVORE FUTURE SIX.
WE'LL BE RIGHT IF
.
IS
LIKE
BETTER WEBSITE
.
GUIDED BY THE
MEMBER.
THEY'VE ISSUES HERE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE FOR.
MISS DAVID CHIU.
THEY CAN THANK CALENDAR.
DAVID CHIU.
BOB ONE.
I'M.
I THINK THE COMPETING.
AB NINETEEN NINETY CORD DAVID
CHIU. HIGH.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX DAVID
CHIU.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ON THE ROLE.
WHO BETTER TO ASK
I DON'T REMEMBER MEDINA HERE?
MEMBER MEDINA HERE LET'S OPEN
THE ROLE FOR MEMBERS OF MEDINA.
THEY CAN THANK CALENDAR.
ANY MEANS.
THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX
MEDINA ODD MEDINA I'M.
A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
EDUARDO GARCIA TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX.
BLOOM TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS MEDINA. MEDINA
AYE.
YES I DO.
LOVE NAME DOES.
INTO A LARGE YEAH.
SO YES I THINK.
FULLER.
MOREOVER THE